even we even we conservatives even
people who take a listen to this show
who listen to the various examples of
this sometimes forget
how crazy the culture has gotten
and then we and then we get reminded
university of georgia has just
issued a mandate to students some
guidance on how to move forward during
covid
do you think the guidance was on how
they can continue to learn how they can
take notes how they can
go to class while protecting themselves
in it no
the guidance was about how when these
teenagers have
sex they should wear masks when they
have sex
it's not a joke is that here's the
guidance consider wearing a face mask
during sex
heavy breathing and panting can further
spread the virus and wearing a mask
can reduce the risk so
i i mean that's all true i get i guess
that's right
but do you remember when when
universities were
in loco parentis when they were when you
know they would kick the girls out of
the dorms
at 9 00 pm or actually before that when
education was single sex
because you were discouraged from having
sex in the culture broadly outside of
marriage
and certainly at universities with all
these now
the the university is giving you tips on
how to get kinky with the co-eds
they're encouraging you to do it and
then but that's kind of you know
perfectly natural you might say then the
next part is even
even wilder they say quote you are your
safest
sex partner practice solo sex
or limit the number of sexual partners
you have so
so limit the numbers like hey they can't
tell you
to uh you know maybe cool it and keep
your modesty and virtue because that
they call that [ __ ] shaving so they say
would you mind maybe limiting the number
of sexual partners you know no more than
three or four a day please and please
practice solo what is solo sex
so i i believe woody allen defined it as
sex with someone who loves you when it's
just you
and you know you turn the blinds down
and you go into your own room
in any case that's a real inversion of
the culture
for the vast majority of the history of
this country
uh sex outside of marriage would be
discouraged sex among teenagers who are
off at
college would be discouraged
masturbation would be discouraged
but we now have a new a new kind of
religious
worldview a new morality and we pretend
that it's
just the absence of religion we pretend
that it's totally neutral but it's not
there's nothing neutral about
encouraging teenagers to have sex with
one another there's nothing neutral
about encouraging masturbation with kind
of
silly euphemisms and things like that
that that is another religious
that's the religious view of the secular
left and we're we are coming to a head
in this religious war cardinal manning i
mention the quote on the show all the
time because it's so true
at bottom all human conflict is
theological
and those are two theologies those are
two
religious views of the world which one
do you want to live in
one is very tempting you know all this
kind of indulgent behavior is
very fun there's a there's a reason that
it's so tempting
but is that what's going to make a good
society is that what's going to make us
good
good people as individuals or are we
going to come to regret that
you know it's it's always fun to have a
lot of drinks at the time it's always
fun you know okay i'll have one more you
know five drinks later
but then you have the hangover the next
day we've got a bit of a cultural
hangover right now
and going back reading those founding
fathers you notice there's a big
difference they make between
liberty and licentiousness liberty where
exercising your freedom
in the true sense of that raising
ourselves up leading to human
flourishing
and licentiousness which is outright
just discouraged or banned or
talked about as sort of the the end of
of free government
licentiousness where you just follow
your own appetites do whatever you want
well now we've got
a culture that i it seems to me that the
christian culture that that founded this
country
promoted liberty and ordered liberty and
this current religion of secular wokism
is promoting nothing other than
licentiousness i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
[Music]
you